وبينما يستمر الغرب في ارسال الاسلحه
الكلاب يحتاج مخزون اسلحه الناتو الى
تجديد عاجل والحرف في اوكرانيا اظهرت ان
الجيوش الغربيه غير مجهزه للحرب تقول هنا
صحيفه
الامريكيه واعتبرت الصحيفه ان الحرب هي
بمثابه جرس انذار لنهضه الجيوش الغربيه
لانه بعد ثلاثه عقود من سقوط جدار برلين
اكتشف الغرب بانهم غير مهيئين لصراع كبير
وطويل الامد بعدما تحولت الحرف اوكرانيا
الى صراع استنزاف لكافه الاطراف لان
المطالب كيافه دائمه لامدادها بالاسلحه
ينظر بالخطر ويفوق قدره الناتو على سبيل
المثال اطلق الجيش الاوكراني ما يقدر بنحو
سبعه الاف قذيفه في اليوم الواحد وهو ما
يعادل عمليا اسبوعين من الانتاج الامريكي
للاسلحه وتحول المستمر الى مدفعيه الناتو
لن يؤدي الا الى زياده على الموردين
الغربيين لان صناعه الاسلحه في اوروبا
مجزئه ومنخفضه
[موسيقى]